that's really quick cool okay okay um
let's see
sammy oh here i brought it to the table
for you
[Laughter]
oh i yeah care um
okay um let's see
max
shot
max sax
okay
um the risk doesn't make sense you're
paying the highest price for a woman
with a history of accepting the lowest
bid often from men that rank lower than
yourself by standards that matters to
men and other men actually that's an
interesting question is like would you
rather a girl's ex be better than you or
worse than you
well i want to be the best she's ever
gone okay five dollars
five dollars from the uk economist
remember the legacy parents leave behind
can like their legacy parents leave
behind can haunt their kids imagine
their teens bullied at school for their
moms only fans five dollars from wesley
anderson social constructs don't always
adhere to reality
um okay
perfect
that's all of them
going back to
her point as well i feel like um wall
smith found like jayden tupac is a great
example because you have one guy who's
like very successful
he
um what i call it
famous actor he's he's done his thing
like
every girl's one of them since like the
90s what not at worst you get two-pack
he's also quite successful as well but
like i thought back in the day
there was a there was a matchup but will
what was it slightly higher but yet jada
still has feelings for dubai to this day
so it's more so it's a bit more deeper
to how successful you are and how much
money you are like he's a great guy
and whatnot but still she still edges
two pack over him kind of thing so it's
quite hard for guys to
to be competing even if you were quite
actually i have a question as guys do
you think that women like choose the
best guys
like if like if you
if you looked at the like the guys on
your your friends or your team or
whatever that like
that the women pick like do you think
girls pick the best guys best guys in
general best guys for them a few sister
if you had a sister
oh yeah no no
no
what do you what kind of guys do you
think girls pick
it depends how old they are depends it
depends that that
like i said it's just the energy really
like if you come with if you come with
them
and and they're really digging your vibe
then they're most likely to pick you but
then at the same time it it like they're
not really looking at
like how much money you're making or
or what you're really doing it's just
really the way you come out that's why
like a girl could go with a broke guy
for a period of time without even
realizing his broke after a while so
yeah now i think um
girls go with the most popular like the
most trending guy who's
who's um who's got the most clout around
them
and um just a couple days ago i think
maybe even yesterday i was watching i
think on twitter and i was talking about
how russell wilson was getting like
ashamed and roast not not shane but like
okay clown for being like a square or
like just like a lame guy
and he's actually like a really good guy
yeah he is
i watched the thing when when he talked
about he went on the podcast as well and
he talks about
um
what he said on his first date with
sierra
and he talked about his um she asked him
about his wallet and his wallet was like
beat up old wallet
and he said um that shows um consistency
like he's a consistent guy like he's
reliable
um because he hasn't changed his wallet
like it's the same one that he's he's
stuck by with he could have got a new
one didn't
and you know we
i say we but popular culture we look at
so um future for example and he's like
glorified and everything but if you put
them
next to each other in terms of
just rating them
russell wilson is more of a desirable
guy man than future but he's just the
future is more
popular he's more he's more out there so
girls will gravitate to him more
he's he's he's a more desirable guy for
long term
i would say long time russell wilson for
sure yeah but for short term
i think it's probably funny you think
girls girls are more attracted to future
is what you're saying but they're more
than younger girls who aren't looking
for
long-term prospects yeah i feel like
depends where it is really like say if
it was a social setting
and then you you had like the rich like
popular cool guys at the corner and then
you just had like let's say like the
regular guys but they're on vim
and they're some of them i don't know
what theirs so if vim means like you're
coming up with good energy like you're
you're actually expressing yourself and
you're letting them know
how you're feeling really where it's
like the boujee the bougie guys who who
obviously have clout yeah they're kind
of chilling because like they're like
they're chilled yeah right yeah more
times like in that sort of situation
like from experience i've seen they
would they would rather go for the loss
less popular guy just just based off
them just off the muscle because they
know where they stand
exactly yeah i hear that what about okay
do you guys think that men choose the
best women
like
based on your friends like the girls
they go after do you think they go after
like quality women or do you think they
go after three or fours
it depends
i don't know but what you would define
like it's up to your interpretation
like i've seen my my friends as soon as
they they're within a nine out of ten or
ten out of ten they just crumble
automatically they're just soft boys
yeah so yeah
i've noticed there's a certain type of
guy that i swear likes girls that are a
little bit mean to them i don't know
what it is yeah
i think that's the same with girls
though too yeah oh first thing
is a very very real thing for sure
what do you think
what about do guys choose the best girls
yeah what do you think
if he has options yes if he doesn't then
he won't okay
from the environment i've been in i've
got to be careful with what i said
he's watching right now who's watching
right now the environment i've been in
and the stuff i've seen
guys do choose the best girl in the end
but
in a particular like period where things
are active
you're going for like the baddest or the
most fun yeah
yeah but when it comes to settling down
[Music]
the the family aspect
they choose the one that's right and i
just have said i've just seen that just
yeah me i've seen it
i have a question okay
for the gentleman in the room yeah um
so you you were saying about the women
in your life you don't sometimes you
don't think they choose the right man
what what what is it for you what is it
that that i mean
yeah so she was so so you guys said like
women don't always like they might pick
future over the other guy
yeah
pearl said you know do you think that
the women in your life choose the best
men
and you said no
what for you then then
quantifies or qualifies the best man if
they're picking who is it that they're
picking
versus what uh versus who you think they
should pick what what what are the
distinguishing characteristics in your
own words
i would say a guy who's going to pro
who's going to provide security for her
emotionally physically and financially
and the bet the guy who can best do that
all three
in my opinion is the best is the better
choice
because thing is the futures of the
world they're not providing that
emotional security for you
probably not they might provide the
physical one if you're if if you're
there but how often is he going to be
with you like once every two weeks every
day
every two weeks
um so that's what i would say the one
the one who
can do all those three in a good good
standard to be honest
oh um
yeah mainly what he said that they just
prioritized like um the girls feelings
emotional security what not not too much
on the uh financial stability-wise but
obviously it'll be nice if they're
financially stable but like the other
two would be more of a priority
pretty much the same what they said just
don't have this
he's he's trustworthy like
the things that needs to get done he
gets it done
and
i feel like with a
you you know you just know you know and
we've all said it here and and so would
you say the same for
women then are these also not things you
would want in terms of someone who's em
financially stable and and
is emotionally
uh intelligent and can be there for you
emotionally and and offer that stability
and who is also trustworthy would you
say that's a universal thing do you
think that's that's the same for women
too no not exactly well i don't
emotional security yes
i don't think guys look to women for
physical security to be honest yeah i
don't think guys look to women for
financial security i don't think most
guys do are you saying that
men
don't care that i can deadlift a lot oh
no they'll care if you can
because if you're taller than most guys
they're definitely looking for you to
be physically secure for them yeah i
want that no
i've seen your bench press is quite
heavy as well
thank you
i will i would jump in here and say so i
was a team gb power lifter
and so i will say yes like and
yeah man but like it's interesting to
see how men react to that like to do
with the strength thing i think for a
lot of guys they're like yo i feel like
i've seen you somewhere
really yeah because team g power that
makes sense right
but um
i i think for it's interesting to see
how guys react to that this is
definitely a side tangent but like it is
really interesting to see how guys react
to that because it's like oh yo you're
like you're strong and [ __ ] you can look
after yourself before that i did emma um
not mma i don't think guys really care
do you think they can i don't i don't i
don't think i don't think i think they
think it's cool i think they go oh
that's you
is it cool to you that i can bench a lot
is it like is it i find it different but
i come from a power lifting background
and it's but um i've seen like a lot of
my friends back in like college and
whatnot they were quite skinny and they
didn't used to hit jim and they talked
about how or if a girl had a bit of
striations or a bit of muscle
automatically they're just cancelled
they just look at him uh stuff like that
yeah oh wow
no i've heard that too that's like so it
depends on the sort of guy really
yeah
i think it's sexual security i think i
think that's something maybe these guys
just
i just think guys like girls in shape
right
yeah a girl who looks after herself yeah
yeah and she doesn't well
she doesn't have to have like a six-pack
or anything like that like but
just a girl who looks after herself
especially if he looks after himself do
you know what i mean